now abayas are a long loose fitting
full-length robe and they are typically
but not exclusively worn by some Muslim
women skin crawling videos show bed bugs
crawling over seats on trains and buses
in Paris as France battles an invasion
of the insects and you dress modestly
for the glory of God everywhere you go
assalamualaikum greetings of Peace how
are you guys doing welcome welcome I got
some very interesting news for you video
footage shared online shows the insects
crawling over seats on the Paris Metro
on high-speed trains and at paris's
Charles de Gaulle Airport as well as
appearing in huge numbers in cinemas and
hospitals the French government has
launched a concerted effort to fight the
bed bug Invasion with transport Minister
Clement bone stating on X that he was
convening representatives from public
transport operators next week to inform
them about countermeasures and how to do
more for the protection of Travelers
this guy right here this guy's trying to
build a Dallas engine or country I'm not
telling you right now you're a solo
you're trying to build a dawa sensor
here Islam is
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters
this is exactly why we need the dean
Center because we have over 300 million
Americans who know nothing about Islam
like this guy
yeah
nine is the most violent chapter of the
Quran the D Center will be a source of
light a mega dawah Center an educational
center helping our brothers and sisters
into Humanity truly understands Islam
and Muslims and brothers and sisters
remember the great rewards of just
guiding one person in humanity to the
truth is better than everything in this
Dunya so get in on all the rewards and
blessings click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
[Music]
subscribe if you have not already hit
that notification Bell if you've
benefited from our programs in the past
present and God willing you will also in
the future so not to miss any of the
programs coming out make sure you
subscribe very interesting story Source
here says Daily Mail friendship citizens
advised to cover their bodies to protect
from recent bed bug outbreak in Paris
the French government has launched a
concerted effort to fight bed bugs which
have appeared in huge numbers on public
transport in cinemas and in hospitals
video footage shared online shows the
insects crawling over seats on the Paris
Metro on high-speed trains and at
paris's Charlize the Galia airport
professionals are advising citizens to
cover their bodies to protect their skin
from being bitten by bed bugs despite
Banning garments bias simply means the
loose fitting clothing about it in
France right now because of the law that
bans any ostentatious display of
religion the education minister of
France says that schools need to be a
sanctuary for secularism however these
garments while they're very popular and
commonplace in a lot of Gulf States
Muslim countries many say they're not
explicitly Muslim and that therefore
this this law is is being abused and
taken out of context as you guys know
recently not too long ago was all over
the news the headlines were and are
reading French Court upholds the Abaya
ban in public schools now when I say I
buy I just want you guys to a place to
buy it with loose fitting clothing so
let's repeat these headlines again
French Court upholds loose clothing ban
in public schools other reports read
such as French schools turn away girls
wearing loose clothing at as Muslim
Rights group challenge band so that was
the issue that came up and now recently
so before it was the loose fitting
clothing bed so basically what France is
doing is if a woman if a if a girl is
wearing
a loose-fitting clothing because there
are conditions to What's called the
hijab this makes it easier for women so
it's just a dress loose clothing that
goes like this
rather than like this okay so what's the
difference clothing that's worn that
goes like this it doesn't reveal the
shape of her body
it's not see-through or transparent it's
loose fitting so that's pretty much what
the fuss was about women who want to
dress in modest apparel they don't want
to be googly-eyed they don't want men
staring at staring them down sexual
gazes at them they want to observe a
modest dress code that's ordained by the
Crater of the heavens and earth God
Allah and now they're being given a very
hard time because of this where
legislation is being passed and now this
starts to come out where French citizens
are advised to cover their bodies to
protect from bed bug outbreak in Paris
while Banning them by a loose clothing
in schools very interesting I want to
hear your guys thoughts what are you
guys thinking here when you hear this so
while we're on this topic of modesty
which for for a Muslim woman a
god-conscious woman is something that is
extremely important this is something
that obviously it goes for a man also a
man should be modest in his behavior and
his character but here we're
particularly talking about the Muslim
woman one who has chosen to submit her
will to the creator of the heavens and
earth that's what a Muslim is you can't
walk out of this building
you can't go anywhere in public and not
see flesh nudity
uh seductresses
dressing to appeal
dressing to look good
you know what I'm talking about
and short and low and here are men who
want to live right
men that want to be holy they got
nowhere to turn because in a 360 degree
circle it's everywhere
but the problem is
is that they have to see it in church
no man
ought to have to fight that in church
and it's interesting now with this note
we'll end but seeing many Christian
pastors who are also speaking on this
who are fed up
ladies girls
when you get up to get dressed to come
to church you ought not to come here to
show off wait your legs and if you're
constantly having to fight to stay
decent you got the wrong wardrobe on and
not just for church but for anywhere
else with some of the indecency that
they're seeing in the churches and
outside the churches of people who also
call themselves Christians and let's
hear what some of these Christian
pastors are saying where we also Co in
line with because Muslim women follow
the example of the one of the best women
to walk the earth this is Jesus's mother
peace be upon him and her they were the
exemplary characters that Muslims also
love and Revere as you know no muslim is
a Muslim unless he or she loves Jesus
peace be upon him
and his blessed mother who women Muslim
women you'll see them imitating in the
loose-fitting clothing the hijab the
proper dress code so it's very
interesting also to see these Christian
Pastors in line
because we have a lot in common and this
is one of those things so let's go ahead
and end with that check this out new
Christians you
you have some first lady in churches
Pastor wives you look like this
you let your children look like this
you let many of the mothers in the
church look like this you go to
so-called Christian concerts and the
women
look like this
the Bible says in like manner oh and
like men are also that women are doing
themselves in modest apparel what is so
modest
about this
that was very interesting to see that
also coming from the Christian Pastor so
let me know what you think in the
comments below going from the Banning of
the loose-fitting clothing in France to
the bed bugs and fans let me know your
thoughts let me know your reaction to
this what do you guys think and we'll
see you next time here in the D show
don't forget if you benefited from this
subscribe hit that notification Bell
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you assalamu alaikum a very good
friend of mine brother Eddie from the
dean show who I've known for a number of
years from the very beginning when he
started it I was among his early guests
and masha'allah our brother Eddie has
been very active in promoting dawa
spreading The Message of Islam and he
has now taken everything to the next
level Eddie has now after a number of
years on The Dean show taking the daup
efforts to the next level which is that
of establishing a tower center for the
USA he is about to launch it in its
fullness but it has already started in
Florida and he needs your support this
is an effort which began already some
months back and they need your support
for spreading The Message of Islam in
the USA so my brothers and sisters reach
out to support him we need your support
now
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum